en este vídeo vamos a ver cómo colocar
la tapa y ajustarla y la razón de esto
es que los cables de cada cableado van a
ser ligeramente diferentes por lo que
tenemos que moverlos un poco para que la
tapa ajuste bien pueden ver que tenemos
varios cables que hay que doblar para
permitir que entre bien la tapa y que
todo se pueda conectar bien a mí se me
está dificultando un poco colocar bien
la tapa sobre todo por estas partes que
sobresalen así que tengo que mover los
cables para que no sean aplastados por
estas partes no es una ciencia exacta se
trata más bien de prueba y error pero ya
que la tenemos bien colocada y bien
asentada nos aseguramos que todos los
cables siguen bien conectados viendo que
la electricidad fluya sin problemas al
encenderlo ahora voy a poner un poco de
silicón caliente y voy a inclinar esto a
un lado para que el silicón fluya hacia
la unión entre la base y la tapa de
manera que todo quede colocado en su
lugar lo que nos permitirá proteger los
cables y dar
el robot un buen aspecto